the top of voters minds here with the
very latest he's had his own big board
our own bill hammer what's interesting
out there is what's going to happen with
these very liberal da's in a couple of
races going on out there uh are they
going to get tough on crime in la san
francisco that should be interesting
yeah i agree with you sean that's really
where the action is tonight on the
screen behind me now you've got the
seven states where their primaries being
held you mentioned california down to
south dakota a moment ago it was called
for christie gnome she has won her
primary
race
uh to be to run again in november as
governor of the state of south dakota
really an easy win for her as you scan
the screen here sean i'll take you
through in a moment
chuck grassley won his primary as well
in iowa so at the age of 88
he will visit all 99 counties in iowa
between now and election day same thing
he's done for a very long time the
senator there from from iowa let's go in
here a little bit you mentioned
california let's go out and uh we'll
start out there in in the golden state
this is san francisco the dhs and bodine
has gotten so much attention for the
progressive policies that he's initiated
going back to january of 2020. all right
what's on the ballot crime and
homelessness right now and the fate of
this uh progressive d.a if you look here
sean
um this is 2020 in yellow in 2022 in red
you see where the assaults went up a
little higher auto theft went higher
larceny theft was just off the charts
for a total crime rate of up of about 10
this is really the story in places like
like san francisco polls closed there an
hour and 20 minutes and we'll see if
bodine can hang on to his office or not
that is san francisco go down the coast
about 10 hours right this is la the
mayor's race going to be very
interesting karen bass has been in
congress for six terms she wants to be
the mayor of los angeles she was looking
really good in this until rick caruso
came along he's a billionaire he's a
developer sean three years ago he was a
republican is running as a democrat
california's rules in the jungle runoff
is that if you don't get to 50
well then you
have a uh
have a runoff in november
meaning you could get two democrats on
the ticket you get two republicans on
the ticket a democrat or republican
whoever the top two vote getters are
they advance for the election in
november
sean los angeles in 2020 was carried
overwhelmingly by bernie sanders
and now they're considering the
possibility of electing a former
republican as their mayor why would that
be well check out the crime statistics
in los angeles 2021 to 2022 robberies
are up in red aggravated assault up and
red total crime up in red as well and
that's what people are voting on in los
angeles
we'll see how it turns out again 11 a.m
east 11 p.m eastern time an hour and 20
minutes from now gas
california
across the country 637 in california
national average 491. i paid 520 the
other day here in new york again it's
the economy
um and and what california wants is a
future quickly i'll go through this this
is the 22nd congressional district in
california why do i point this out this
is republican david
david valadeo he voted to impeach
president trump he's got several
challengers three on screen president
trump has not endorsed any one of these
challengers
here in california take you here to iowa
this is a target republicans think a
super vulnerable seat they think a
democrat cindy axne she'll be up for
reelection in november they redrew her
district a little bit des moines is
right here and that down here in the
rural area in iowa she has some big
challengers on the republican side
because of what happened in 2020 she won
her district but donald trump clipped
joe biden in the same district and they
think this is a this could be a pickup
for republicans in november we will be
looking sean for the next five months
now at these republican targets some
people think it's 25 some people think
it's 35 some people think it could be as
high as 50. we'll find out over the
coming summer months and into the fall
but that's where we are as of now
california one hour and 16 minutes away
tonight
bill hammer phenomenal job is always at
the big board it used to be the hannity
big board but you stole it you took it
away and you're better at it so great
job as usual thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else